el allanamiento pues la libertad de
prensa un tema espinoso para ramón
zamora el mismo día que encarcela habana
a su padre reconocido periodista de
oposición también allanaban su lugar de
trabajo ese 29 de julio ocho
trabajadores fueron retenidos durante 16
horas en las rotativas del matutino el
periódico en la ciudad de guatemala fue
sumamente violento y violento muchos
derechos porque al final de cuentas en
ningún momento notificar a un por qué
estaban entrando que fue muy similar a
lo que sucedió en la casa de mis padres
mientras dos tapas no acá sin tocar la
puerta de sin que el nadie les abría la
puerta de la casa se subieron al techo
para ingresar a la casa de mis padres
la detención de josé rubén zamora por
cargos de lavado de dinero y
conspiración es considerada por sus
abogados como un montaje político
importe su historial de investigaciones
periodísticas acabó por costarle la
libertad sobre todo el trabajo donde
vinculó directamente al presidente
alejandro giammatei con casos de
corrupción nunca nadie pensó que en
papeles para pasar algo por ser un
periodista tan reconocido
internacionalmente y si a él le pasó lo
que le está pasando quiere decir que a
cualquier periodista les puede pasar
otro medio históricamente crítico es el
grupo prensa libre su jefe de redacción
a antonio barrios teme por el futuro de
los medios in guatemala y el país está
en una situación caminando poco a poco
hacia un clima muy tenso hacia hacia un
clima totalitario probablemente una
realidad a la que andrea domínguez se
enfrenta en el terreno etiquetada de
periodista de oposición por el gobierno
muchas veces le cuesta hacer su trabajo
sí soy de posición notarás una
entrevista demandar yo y ser antenas en
algún impacto público él incluso se
burla de los periodistas guatemala no
deja de caer en la clasificación de la
libertad de prensa de reporteros sin
fronteras posicionándose este año en el
puesto 124 de los 180 países